Nos dicen que: "Cada cuadrado grande representa
un entero. Expresa el área sombreada como un
número mixto y también como un decimal". Pusa
el video y trata de encontrar la respuesta.
¿Cómo podemos expresar esto como un número mixto
y cómo podemos expresarlo como un decimal? Bien,
vamos a resolverlo juntos. Empecemos con el número
mixto. Podemos ver que aquí tenemos un entero,
todo el cuadrado está sombreado así que tenemos
1 entero, y de este lado sólo tenemos una parte
sombreada. Ahora bien, parece que este cuadrado
está dividido en 10 secciones iguales y solamente
2 de ellas están sombreadas, entonces, como
número mixto podemos decir que tenemos 1 entero
y después tenemos 2 de 10 partes sombreadas,
por lo tanto esto es igual a 1 entero 2/10,
y lo hemos logrado. Observa: esta parte está
dividida en décimos y sólo hay 2 de ellos
coloreados. Ahora, ¿cómo lo podemos expresar
como decimal? Bueno, para expresar 1 entero
y 2/10 como decimal vemos que esto es igual a 1 y
después nos movemos a la posición de los décimos,
¿cuántos décimos tenemos? Bueno, tenemos 2
décimos, así que esto es igual a 1.2. Bien,
hagamos otro ejemplo. Aquí tenemos algo
ligeramente más complicado. De nuevo nos
dicen que: "Cada cuadrado grande representa
un entero. Expresa el área sombreada como
una fracción y también como un decimal". Pausa
el video y trata de resolverlo por tu cuenta.
Bien, una vez más empecemos con la fracción. Aquí
tenemos 1 entero, 2 enteros y después tenemos un
tercer entero parcialmente sombreado. Entonces,
si queremos expresar todo esto como una fracción
realmente será un número mixto, así que vamos a
escribir un número mixto. Podemos ver que todo
esto corresponde a 2 enteros mientras que de este
lado sólo tenemos una parte sombreada y observa
que se encuentra dividido en centésimos, porque
tenemos una cuadrícula de 10 por 10, por lo tanto,
cada uno de estos cuadros representa 1 centésimo
del entero. ¿Cuántos de estos centésimos tenemos?
Bueno, aquí tenemos 10, 20, 30, 40, 50,
60, 70, y después tenemos 71, 2, 3 y 4;
podemos ver que 74 cuadritos de los 100 que hay
en total en este tercer entero están sombreados,
así que como número mixto todo esto representa 2
enteros y 74/100. Y ahora, si queremos escribirlo
como decimal tenemos 2 enteros y después nos
ubicamos en la posición de los décimos, bueno
podemos simplemente escribir 2 enteros y 74/100
si estás familiarizado con esto, justo así. Pero
también lo podemos expresar en términos de cuántos
décimos y centésimos tenemos. En este caso tenemos
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 décimos y después tenemos 4
centésimos más, por lo tanto, podemos verlo como
74 centésimos o 7 décimos y 4 centésimos,
pero de cualquier manera ya terminamos.